this one is the five favorite films well
that's a five favorite films as of
yesterday the 400 blows love the music
love the story love the ending just you
know as he runs and he sees the ocean
for the first time beautiful to me that
one was the one that when I saw it I
want to like wow I want to see more
Lucia is a Cuban film it's a great story
of three different moments in history
and Cuban history seen through the eyes
of of three women and the last story of
Adele allegorize her name and I think
she gives one of those performances that
is like you know Brando ask it's like
she's so good in it it's just a movie
that I think it's still important today
let's talk about Jimmy Cliff let's talk
about one hell of a soundtrack and one
hell of a movie just one of those films
that it's like the more I watch it the
more I discover and the more I enjoy it
it's a great moving story that you're
rooting for this guy and he's got all
these obstacles and you just you just
feel for the guy and then he starts
becoming this antihero and you can't
help it but understand him it's one of
those movies when I was a kid I i loved
all those monster movies growing up in
puerto rico as a kid The Creature from
the Black Lagoon was a monster that
could live and the humidity and the heat
and was that monster that could be
rapping on my window it's a beautiful
story in a way you root for the monster
he just falls in love and they're
invading his Lagoon you know so so you
kind of like you root for the monster
and I you know the monster becomes kinda
like a victim the last detail Nicholson
and Jack Nicholson at his best old is
young and Rani Quay is one of those
movies that it's like a great road
picture but also you know just
complicated relationships you know and
great great scenes and a lot of heart
and there's an element of the futility
of effort you know and in it you know
one day at the end when they return
Randy Quaid when they take him to jail
and they hand him off it's just you know
Nicholson that is best